Paris,
San Bernardino,
Jerusalem,
Brussels,
it seems not a day goes by without
another murderous assault on innocent
civilians.
Last Sunday bore witness to one of the
most horrific attacks in recent memory
as a Taliban affiliated group,
um,
to park in Lahore,
Pakistan,
killing scores of women and children
celebrating the Easter holiday.
These attacks only seem to be getting
more brazen,
more coordinated,
and more effective.
People all over Europe are worried and
with good reason.
It seems governments all throughout the
European continent had been ill prepared
to deal with the growing threat of
radical Islamic terrorism.
Please note,
I once again said radical Islamic
terrorism and not all Muslims.
I think I've done that once or twice
before.
This distinction is becoming
increasingly exhausting to have to point
out,
but one I continue to make
unfortunately,
many on the right refuse to separate the
nominal average person from the radicals
and many on the left refuse to
acknowledge there are a few of us who do
make that distinction over and over.
While I've now conceded that the far
left will never accept any good faith
critique of Islam and will always excuse
and sometimes even endorse it's
terrorism.
I know that many good people are waking
up to this nonsense every day.
This is one of the themes the rubin
report has been all about,
and I'm glad to say that we're ahead of
the curve on it,
so one more time.
It is radical Islamists,
a subset of people who believe in Islam,
who are blowing up airports,
trains,
and parks.
They don't care whether the people they
murder are men or women,
grandparents or children,
black or white.
They want to sow chaos and destruction
in the name of their religion.
Don't take my word for it by the way,
read the statements,
the jihadists issue after each terror
attack,
these statements are all filled with
religious reasons,
quoting doctrine to kill infidels and
nonbelievers.
This is a good time to remind people.
Once again what a religion is.
It is a set of ideas or religion isn't
built into you like your sex or your
color or religion is just a bunch of
ideas only made of reality by people who
practice it's beliefs.
Any set of ideas is worthy of critique.
Whether these ideas are religious,
political or personal,
so if you would be against throwing gays
off of roofs,
making women wear burkas and treating
minorities as second class citizens.
If a political party had those ideas and
its platform,
then you must be against those ideas.
When a religion has them in its doctrine
and for the billionth time,
this doesn't mean you should be bigoted
against all people who practice that
faith because there are a multitude of
ways of being part of any faith.
What it does mean however,
is that at the very least,
you must be against the ideas that you
would be against if they came from
anywhere else besides religion.
Actually,
you should be much braver than just
being against bad ideas.
You should impact stand for good ideas
or one day the violence you silently
condone will be at your doorstep.
This is why the regressive left is so
dangerous.
They've tricked decent people with good
intentions into thinking that they're
legitimate fears about terrorism or
somehow bigoted or racist.
Not only is this pure nonsense,
but he has also fueled the rise of the
right wing parties in Europe and Donald
Trump here in America.
The ideas of the regressive left have
gone from wrong to malicious screaming
about the crusades.
Every time there is a jihadist attack is
pointless.
Focusing on one random atheist who
committed a mass shooting is irrelevant.
These regressives or trying to guilt and
confuse you into accepting their
backwards thinking.
We in the west,
fortunately can't stand up to jihadist
face to face,
but we absolutely must stand up to those
in our own societies who will excuse
people who would kill us due to their
misguided sense of protecting a
religion.
Ironically,
this disease of the mind which
regressive thinking really is,
is the furthest thing from progressive
values,
but also is an added bonus for the
jihadists.
They can kill scores of people and then
their Western allies will do mental
gymnastics to excuse and explain why
they did it.
The more that jihad is,
say it's about religion,
the more the regressive say it isn't
generally I find jihadists to be more
honest than regressive,
so I'm going to take their word for it.
The world is at a precarious point.
We can debate how much foreign policy is
enabled jihadists or whether America's
toppling of Saddam Hussein led to Isis.
Of course,
we can go much further back in history
to the British empire or the Ottoman
Empire even further.
These blood feuds have gone on for
thousands of years and will probably go
on until after we're all gone.
The question is,
will we in western societies now stand
together and no longer accept excuses
for terror?
If you feel the need to make an excuse
when a bomb goes off in a Paris theater,
you're inviting terrorism to your
farmer's market.
In Los Angeles,
people will always have a grievance and
if you tell them that it's an acceptable
to murder innocent because of your
western guilt or misguided sense of
justice,
then you are condemning yourself to a
world where there are no rules.
We will all live between terrorists
trying to kill us and Authoritarians who
will promise us safety.
It's a false choice,
but it's exactly where we are headed.
If good people won't stand up.
Now,
I'm not sure how many jihadists watched
the show,
but I'm pretty sure many good and decent
people do start calling out this
regressive thinking in your own world,
stopping being cowed by false cries of
racism or bigotry.
Start beating their self flagellation
with the truth about why Western society
is good.
The Islam is earned bed with liars and
regressive conmen.
Their ideas will spread faster.
If we don't wake up now and if you think
this is a job for someone else,
then this evil alliance has already won.
I don't think it has,
but I know we need more vocal allies.
One such ally is my guest this week,
Julie Lunars,
Julie's a terrorism expert and director
of the Human Security Center in London.
She's on the front lines of calling out
radical Islam for the danger that it is.
I'm looking forward to talking to her
about some difficult topics and maybe
I'll even ask her about those pesky
crusade.
Remember,
if you're still upset about the
Crusades,
which happened a thousand years ago,
then you should be at least equally
upset about the ones happening.
Right now.
Julie Lynn,
ours is the executive director of the
Human Security Center and a principal
consultant to the European Parliament
intergroup on religious freedom.
Julie,
welcome to the show.
So good to beat him.
Uh,
I'm really excited to talk to you
because I've been following you on
twitter for probably three years or so
and you've really been ahead of the
curve on calling out Islamist extremist
terror or Islamic extremists terror or
jihadist terror or whatever phrase you
want to use.
Y'All let you break down some phrases.
You've been ahead of it.
And one of the people that when I see
with the things that you tweet,
I'm always like,
she gets it.
She understands it.
A.
So let's start.
What brought you to this spot?
How did you get involved in being one of
the people that studies this,
that talks about it,
that consulted about it?
When I read my first book on politics
when I was 12,
and I know that probably makes me sound
like a complete geek.
I read my first book on politics when I
was 12 about the conflict in Ireland
about Northern Ireland and I was
interested in why people were healing
for their belief and for their ideology.
And of course Ireland was more about
national terrorism rather than religious
terrorism.
I mean there was a religious component
in the sense that you have,
you had the IRA on the one hand that was
kept clinic and you had the Uda and the
other power metallic power monetary,
um,
organizations that were Protestant or
the other items.
But anyway,
I mean that's how I got interested in,
in conflict and white people were
killing in holiness and people for their
beliefs.
And then two years later,
of course,
nine slash 11 happens and I report in at
the time I remember it,
acid acid was yesterday.
I wasn't in school that day.
I was at home.
I was ill,
I was sitting on the couch,
I was watching random television and
suddenly this horrific images it pay it
on my screen and obviously my first
reaction was this was a terrible,
terrible tragedy,
an accident.
But the moment,
the second plane hit the towers,
I think everybody knew that whatever it
was and that the time,
obviously we were still lacking the
rhetoric to describe what just happened.
I realized that this was a game changer,
that the world would never be the same
again.
And that is true.
I mean the world was never the same
again after 9:11
and an obviously Afghanistan happened in
Iraq happened and when we went into
Iraq,
I was 16 at the time.
And I think that was really the moment I
would describe as my awakening in the
sense that I realized we were not just
fighting the enemy from the outside,
but also the enemy within.
And I'm not talking about the people who
post a wolf a perfectly legitimate
reasons,
more everything's strategic reasons.
Um,
I'm talking about the people who
hijacked the antiwar movement and who
were happy to call George George W dot
Bush and Tony Blair war criminals,
while at the same time turning around
and embracing people.
I come as a terrorist organization,
had prejudice genocide against the Jews
and people like George Galloway who was
on record praising Saddam Hussein,
some courage strings in project
finishes.
And that was the moment when I realized,
guys,
we really have a problem and we need to
talk about this.
Yeah.
So I really want to dive into that
because it's a,
it's so related to everything we've been
talking about here,
this sort of moral confusion that people
seem to have in a lot of it
unfortunately does seem to be on the
left and the right's got plenty of moral
confusion itself.
Um,
but yeah,
we seem to see a lot of that.
I left.
That's interesting.
So because you were young around the
time that nine slash 11 happened.
I'm a little older than you.
I was in.
I lived in New York City at the time and
of course I had studied politics before,
but of course it was a defining moment
for me and for literally millions of
people as well.
So the.
So all that happens.
And then when did you actually start
working in this field and really sort of
talking about this publicly and making
that your,
your life's work?
Well,
I actually started writing a personal
blog at the time the war in Iraq
happened and I talked about it a lot.
I mean that was the first thing I really
talked about publicly a lot about the
reasons why.
Even though,
as I said before,
I always had great respect for the
people who opposed the war for perfectly
legitimate reasons that I.
However,
there was also a more legitimate case
for the wall.
I mean,
look at the torture chambers and the
concentration camps and the genocide
against the Kurds.
I think it was a,
a former Kaddish president who once said
that Iraq was a concentration camp above
ground,
above ground and a mass grave beneath.
And that was true.
It was one of the worst dictatorships on
earth and that's when I really got
involved in this debate and was exposed
to dwight a public and that was also the
time really when people started
attacking me for my views.
Yeah.
So when,
when people talk to you about the Iraq
war now,
I mean,
the meme in America is that,
you know,
had we not toppled George had George W
had we not topple George W Bush,
George W Bush,
uh,
not,
not toppled Saddam,
that ultimately had we not gone into
Iraq that,
that would have,
that isis wouldn't be here basically is
the,
is the idea that,
and you know,
as I've talked to some experts in this,
a lot of people are saying,
well,
Saddam,
as you just said,
was doing some pretty horrific things.
So despite knowing now that there
weren't weapons of mass destruction or
at least that we never found them,
do you still in your mind,
do you feel that that what we did was
still a moral case and what you guys did
as well?
And obviously,
uh,
you know,
Tony Blair had something to do with it.
Yes,
I still believe,
I still believe after everything that it
was right to,
to topple this regime and you know,
some of some of the things that people
were saying,
why we shouldn't intervene,
like at least Saddam Hussein contains.
Iran for me really never was a moral
argument.
You cannot contain one dictatorship with
a theocratic regime and vice versa.
And um,
for the curb it was a liberation.
I mean,
look at Kurdistan today,
Iraqi Kurdistan as a beacon of hope in
the entire region.
And,
um,
I obviously,
I obviously I'm acknowledged that we did
something's terribly wrong,
which led to bloodshed and chaos.
The dismantling of the Iraqi army to
debar certification.
All of the big things really,
um,
I think were catastrophic and I'm really
happy to admit that,
but it doesn't change the fact for me
that this was a genocidal dictator.
I mean,
he committed a crime of all crimes.
Ninety five percent of Kurdish villages
were exposed to chemical weapons during
the DNF pumpkins pain.
And that is still the reason why I still
believe after everything,
that it was the right thing to do.
Yeah.
And that's not even to talk about what
he was doing to dissidence and free
thinkers and secular,
secularism,
all of them.
Yeah.
So tell me a little bit about the type
of work that you do now.
What,
what's actually the base work that
you're doing?
Well,
we do different things.
We work with the government,
a government,
of course we work with non governmental
organizations.
We've worked with media,
we work with the public and we do public
outreach.
I'm.
One of the things that we currently
doing is we're working with a European
Parliament intergroup on religious
freedom and um,
what,
what we're doing for them.
Basically it's a once a year we are
looking at the worst violators of
religious freedom across the world.
Everything is really old continent from
Latin America to Asia to,
to um,
um,
to Africa.
And we,
we look at the sources of persecution,
we look at why religious minorities in
that particular country are targeted and
by whom they are targeted and what we
can do to help these people.
Alright.
So who's doing most of the targeting?
Well,
first of all,
it,
it is a,
it is a phenomenon and affect all
countries across all continents really.
And it also affects all religions.
Of course you have a,
you have,
for instance,
the brutal persecution of Muslims in
Burma by Buddhist extremists.
And do you have the persecution of
Muslims by Christian minutia and the
Central African Republic or you have,
um,
you have the persecution of Christians
by Hindu nationalists in India,
but the vast majority of religious
persecution we see in the world today
has some kind of relation to the
religion of Islam,
whether it's by a state actor or a non
state actor.
I had a feeling that's what you were
going to say.
So because we're,
we're the good guys in this case and we
try to separate people from ideas.
How do you guys,
when you're studying this and you're
learning about this,
how do you separate what is done in the
name of religion in the name of doctrine
versus just the geo political realities
on the ground?
When I mean,
um,
we,
we looked,
for instance at,
at the law of the country and the
constitution of the country and what you
will find at many of these countries is
that the constitution in itself already
discriminates against minorities.
So for instance,
the president of the country can only be
Muslim and um,
that is of course not just something
that,
that is purely decided on religious
grounds.
It's also a strategic decision,
right?
I mean they want to,
to,
to keep to themselves,
but then you also have completely
irrational persecution of minorities who
can't do any harm whatsoever to the
state because they are a tiny minorities
and they are deprived of all their
rights.
And that is of course,
when it's no longer strategic and when
it really comes down to religious
doctrine.
And I'm talking for instance about the
Ahmadiyya Muslims,
the values,
uh,
in,
in Sunni Muslim states often does she,
um,
again,
that is both related to religion.
Enter your politics are often,
it's also a mixture of both.
And it's very difficult to tell what it
is for political or religious reasons
that people are being persecuted.
But yeah,
I mean that definitely is a problem that
we have with religious inspired
persecution of minorities in the Muslim
world.
So I know you do a lot of work with and
for the Kurds.
We've been talking a bit about the Kurds
here.
It's incredibly under reported,
especially in the states.
Um,
are they the best example of a
persecuted minority because they're a
minority in at least four countries.
They never got their state when the
whole thing was carved up and they were
basically treated incredibly poorly by
Turkey,
Iraq,
Iran,
and Syria.
So are they really the best example for
you when you were talking about this
kind of stuff?
Well,
you know,
I was,
I was joking a couple of weeks ago that
I should get myself a tee shirt saying I
supported the cats before it became
fashionable because now be know a lot of
people talk about them and don't get me
wrong,
I'm,
I'm really,
really pleased that people are finally
giving them the attention and exposure
that these wonderful and openminded and
largely peaceful and brave people
deserve.
And yes,
I,
I honestly believed that probably since
the formation of the state of Israel in
the 19 forties at what we're seeing with
the Kurds,
the struggle for self determination is
probably the most promising democracy
experiment in the Middle East because
low had one,
the curts are doing,
I mean the Iraquis can,
if you,
if you take Iraqi Kurdistan as an
example,
we're just a semi autonomous region and
in the north of the country they have
their own president and prime minister
in Parliament and the passion of God,
which is we just eat the,
the army of off the Kurdistan region.
I mean they have taken hundreds of
thousands of people from Syria,
from Iraq,
persecuted by the Islamic state,
hunted body outside regime,
including tens of thousands of
Christians who otherwise would have been
slaughtered or at least enslaved.
They were able to celebrate Easter in
safety and peace.
And it's not just that they are
providing basic needs to these people.
They are going a step further.
They are actually trying to support the
rights of religious minorities.
And last year,
the Kurdistan region of Iraq did
something that I feel is absolutely
unique and historic.
They decided to give to each of the
minority minority communities,
religious minority communities in Iraqi
Kurdistan,
the official representation.
So they all have their own
representatives now and not just one.
It's not just the Muslims and the
Christians.
No.
Also the Jews and the buys and to show
that the shoebox and and Ahmadiyya
Muslims were persecuted all across the
Muslim world.
And you know,
these are not just token appointment.
These guys are really doing work that
the first Jewish represented just comes
back from a visit from Israel where he
met with lawmakers and always trying to
really find ways to build bridges
between Israel and Kurdistan.
And this is absolutely unique in that
region.
And it's fascinating if you think about
the defect that just miles away from
Erbil where the,
where the Kurdish parliament sets the
stage is,
you know,
is,
is in place.
And that is of course the most
fundamental manifestation of radical
Islam
had a few weeks ago who is the,
uh,
the Krg rep to the United States.
And we were talking about that border
and how close everything is and it's
really crazy because basically the
Kurds,
the peshmerga,
they are fighting the isis on one side
and then they're also fighting Turkey on
the other side and Turkey as a NATO
ally.
Can you explain a little bit of the
complexity there?
Because it's really complex because
there are also Kurds in Turkey and they
have a political party and they're
trying to negotiate with Turkey.
It doesn't sound like it's going that
well.
Yep.
You have to make a distinction between
the Kurds in Iraq and the cat's in
theory.
I ended up the text and the cuts and
Turkey and the cuts and in Iran because
they all have different goals and they
all have different relationships with.
With Turkey as well.
The relationship between the Kurdistan
region of Iraq with Turkey is actually
not that bad.
It's a.
it's the problem with the PK K in in
Turkey,
that is in for many years now.
I'm trapped in a brutal conflict with
the Turkey stage and of course the PKK
is allied to the GPJ in Syria,
which now controls almost the entire
border with Turkey and Turkey is bonding
the Kurds,
the same people we are working with,
the US is working with to find Islamic
state.
So what we actually seeing is that the
US net coalition is at war with itself.
Yeah.
So what,
what is that?
Because it seems like this is now an
open secret that this is happening.
The Kurds are fighting isis on the
ground.
They're basically the only fighting
force on the ground fighting Isis and
Turkey is bombing them.
And we are a NATO ally with Turkey.
So how is this secret being allowed?
It's being,
it's out and we're not doing anything
about it.
Well,
what Europe needs the cooperation of the
Turkish state because of the refugee
crisis,
right?
Turkey in many ways from the gateway
from Syria to Europe.
And they need to go on to play a play
along.
And that is one of the reasons why so
many governments in Europe,
uh,
hesitant to criticize the Turkish
government for the way they're treating
the cuts both in own country and also in
theory.
So Turkey basically is having their cake
and eating it too,
and that they're letting the fighters in
through Europe,
right?
They come from Europe,
they go through Turkey,
they go in and then Turkey is then
bombing the Kurds because they're not
thrilled with the Kurds.
So it's good for them.
And then we have to play ball with them
because they're also the buffer zone.
So it really,
that's like one of those cases where you
can really see how complex this stuff
is.
Yeah,
I mean basically what do you can say is
that Turkey is more afraid of a Kurdish
stage than it is Islamic stage.
And that's exactly.
I mean,
if you look at that policy and the way
they react in the region,
I think that that's crystal clear.
And we,
we,
we can't,
uh,
we can't really deny that.
And I personally agree with you that
it's,
it's absolutely shameful that a NATO
partner is bonding with the group of
people that is most efficient in
fighting the Islamic state.
Now,
I'm not condemning by any means the
terrorist attacks that we've seen in
Turkey by the PKK.
No,
no.
Terrorism is ever justified against
anyone.
I,
I con I rejected when you some extent is
doing that.
I rejected when the IRA was doing that
in Northern Ireland.
I rejected when the PKK is doing that in
Turkey,
but it's more complex than just the PKK
and the Turkeys state.
I mean this goes way beyond Turkey just
taking action against the PKK.
They're really using this to sort of
justify an entire crackdown on,
on the Kurds within Turkey and the Kurds
in Syria.
And this basically goes hunting it hand
in hand with an increased all three,
um,
authoritarianism inside Turkey.
If you look at the crackdown on the
media,
free speech activists,
this all goes hand in hand.
It's not just the,
the cuts that being targeted,
it's freethinkers.
Everybody you to criticize President
Erdogan.
Yeah.
So I want to back up to something that
you said about the Kurds a moment ago
that they've sent a representative to
Israel and I know that there is
supposedly some other sort of behind the
scenes relationships there,
but does that sort of proved that at the
end of the day,
regardless of what religion people are,
uh,
that really that having sort of the base
human freedom and respect for minorities
and things like that,
that that's what will make these
countries succeed or fail.
It's not a coincidence that the
countries that seem to fail are the
least tolerant.
So that's a relationship that should be
nurtured further.
Right?
Well,
absolutely.
And uh,
I think what would you say is absolutely
true.
The cut are the best example because
let's not forget they are Muslims.
The vast majority of are Muslims and yet
they practice and if not that is
inclusive and respectful to other
people.
And it is possible.
It's not,
it's not mutually exclusive to be Muslim
as,
as a person and be,
be open minded towards others.
And the coke have a long standing
history and culture of tolerance and
peaceful coexistence.
So in,
in that way,
yes,
the kids really are the best example and
the beacon of hope and a region that is
otherwise drowning in blood and,
and,
and my mom,
right.
And it also,
it's a beautiful thing because it shows
that religions can,
don't always have to be their extremist
parts,
uh,
and that they're using street.
There are strategic reasons in that area
that they might want to partner up with
Israel and things.
So it gets the religion out of it and it
gets some of the Geo politics out of it.
Yes.
And it's quite interesting if you go to
Kurdistan and he talked to two people
about Israel and about America,
you don't get this hostility that you
get in many Arab countries where they
perceive and Israel and America is the
worst of everything.
And now we got,
you get a very different attitude in
Kurdistan where they are looking at
Israel and looking at American.
They're looking at our science and
technology.
You know,
leave aside politics for a moment,
look and everything else,
you know,
the lutheranism that we have,
the freedoms that we have,
freedom of speech to everybody,
you know,
has the right to do whatever they say in
what they admire,
that they inspire,
they inspire to be like us,
not in the sense that they were giving
up their own culture,
but having an open minded view of the
world that is compatible with the 21st
century.
Yeah.
Alright.
So let's shift we,
I mean,
we could spend,
so it's so complex that we could spend
the rest of the hour talking about it,
but let's shift to some of the other
stuff going on right now.
So obviously there was the attack in
Brussels last week,
just a few days ago.
There was the attack in Pakistan.
It seems to me that these things are
starting to become more frequent and
there's just a feeling that now,
you know,
I saw something this week that they're
saying that there's probably 400 isis
operatives in Europe ready to partake in
whatever the next event is going to be.
Um,
so can you just break down Brussels a
little bit because I know for,
for weeks before people were saying this
was about to happen.
Uh,
so they obviously had good intelligence
and it still happened and I think that's
what the really scary part is.
Yes.
I mean obviously what happened in Russia
is absolutely horrific,
but it was not up to me at least,
it was not a surprise,
you know,
it was coming.
We knew that and you were just saying
that obviously we had good intelligence.
Well you have to distinguish the Abbott,
but because obviously the Belgian
authorities didn't have the intelligence
that they were supposed to be having.
And that is a problem that people like
myself who have raised for quite a long
time now that the very weak nature of
the Belgian state.
I mean,
it's sometimes even problematic to speak
of Belgium as a state because it's so
torn apart in eternity.
And the state of the Belgian,
um,
secret services and intelligence
services,
they are inequipped.
They are massively undecided and they
simply don't have the resources to
monitor all the people that they're
actually supposed to be monitoring
because let's not forget that Belgium
has the highest percentage per capita of
foreign fighters do some estate in the
entire European Union and it's no,
it's no coincidence that these people
have chosen Belgium as a place where
they can gather and plan and carry out a
text because of course there are well
aware of all these weaknesses that I've
just missed it and you know,
by failing their own people,
Belgium is putting everyone else at risk
because obviously these people do not
appreciate nation states.
You know,
someone in France,
someone in Germany or the UK.
It's just as much an enemy to these
people as the people of Belgium and it
can openly cross borders.
I mean we have,
we still have the Schengen area in,
in Europe where people can cross borders
without showing that passport or a new
form of identification.
And that's why we're seeing the
terrorism that we see.
And that's also why we see a network
really spamming from.
From Paris to Belgium.
And this was the first time ever that
one terrorist cell managed to attack to
European capitals?
Yeah.
Did you hear any?
I saw a story that I saw in one place
and then I didn't see a picked up
anywhere else.
So if this is not true,
please stop me.
But I heard that when they were going to
arrest the guy in Belgium just a week
ago,
that apparently that in his community
that about 200 people we're trying to
stop the police and the anti terror
people from arresting and they were
throwing bottles at the police and all
kinds of stuff.
Did you hear about that and is it being
reported in Europe at all?
I heard about that as well.
I think some media outlets reported that
there were riots taking place when they
arrested him and to be honest,
it's not surprising to me at all because
you have to understand these people
don't work in isolation.
They are embedded in communities and if
you look at these notorious
neighborhoods like molenbeek and
mountain,
it's not just the terrorists that are
the problem.
It's the wider society in which they
live who may be on not jihad this
themselves and who not engaged in
violence themselves,
but who are at least to a certain degree
described to the Islamist ideology,
which brings me to the overall problem
really that it's not good enough to say
this is just a problem with a fringe
because yes,
there there is only a tiny minority that
carries out violent attacks,
but there is a lot of minority that
subscribed to the Islamic world view and
an even larger minority,
a significant minority that practices
conservative Islam that is not
compatible with the modern world and we
are not talking a few hundred or a few
thousand people.
Here we are talking millions and even if
you say that just one percent of all
Muslims in the world.
Do you hot it?
We are talking about 15 or 16 million
people.
I mean wrap your hand around for a
moment.
Yeah,
no,
it's incredible.
And I know that many people like Sam
Harris,
who I've had on this show have gone out
of their way to talk about these
concentric circles and you have the
nominal people who don't necessarily
care about religion or following
doctrine,
and then it sort of extends outward from
that.
So what do,
what do we do with that?
Because this is where the conversation
gets difficult.
So you've obviously just laid out there
that you don't think all Muslims are
doing this,
but you do see a certain amount of
problems.
A certain amount of people are going to
use violence.
condone that violence.
A certain amount of people are gonna see
it brewing in their communities and not
do anything.
And then it just keeps.
It's like an onion.
There's just more and more layers.
So how do we in the West combat that
because we're fighting,
we're fighting the people,
we're fighting them,
and then we're fighting the people on
our left who are trying to silence us
from talking about it.
One good example,
it's your show really because you equip
people with the rhetoric to to engage in
just daily live in these debates as well
and to make the distinction between the
religion of Islam,
which is a set of eaves and Islamism,
which is an ideology which partly
derived from a particular interpretation
of the religion and jihadism,
which Dennis sort of the violent
extension of Islam Islam.
So I think that's first of all a
distinction that's very important to me
because it also makes it easier for
people like ourselves to reject,
you know,
charges of racism and bigotry and
Islamophobia
doesn't get exhausted by making the
distinction though because it almost
doesn't win you any friends on the left
because that's how I feel.
But I'll continue to do it.
Exactly.
I mean I don't really have another
choice.
Right.
I mean the other option would be to,
to,
to join Don Donald Trump's camp and just
generalize and stigmatize or Muslims and
that's really not what I want to see
mean.
That is precisely why I'm not a bigger,
that's a race because I don't want to
engage in these generalizations and
sweeping statements and brushing every,
everyone over the same Ta.
I don't want to do that and that is why
I keep explaining to people there is a
difference between a religion and Islam
is a religion like any other religion.
It is a set of beliefs and we should
have the right to criticize particular
beliefs within the faith if they are
harmful and incompatible with modern way
of life and it was sometimes called
sometimes called Islam the virgin
amongst faith because you are not
allowed to touch it.
You are not allowed to touch virgin.
They are happy to discuss with you
gender inequality when it comes to
Orthodox Judaism and they are quite
happy to discuss with you bigoted views
on the fundamentalist.
Christian write about abortion and women
and gay.
Don't forget about the crusades,
the Crusades,
what I say all the time,
but don't forget what we did 200 years
ago.
Know they talk about the persecution of
Muslims in Burma by,
by Buddhist extremists and they're not.
They don't hesitate to call them
extremists and make the religion and
the,
the link to the religion of Buddhism.
But when it comes to Islam,
it's off topic.
You are not allowed to touch Islam.
The moment you touch Islam,
you're a bigot.
You're a racist no matter what
distinction you're making between the
religion and ideology and m and g,
how does him.
You're a racist that very moment.
You want to talk about Islam?
Yeah.
So basically you'll continue to make
this distinction because we sort of have
no choice.
I mean,
that's how,
that's how I feel too,
because I don't want to hand it to the
far right.
But that's a good segue to a lot of
what's happening in Europe right now.
So you mentioned earlier that because of
the European Union,
uh,
you know,
that they're,
the people don't have to use passports
to go all over the place.
So this is why the ideology can spread
and it's white people can,
can go from Paris to Brussels.
Um,
so two questions here.
One is people seem to want.
There's a certain amount of people that
want to break up the EU altogether.
Uh,
and secondly,
I want to talk about immigration as a
whole.
So why don't we start with the first
one?
Why don't we see that there is a debate
going on everywhere in Europe about open
borders because many people feel like
I'm no longer an asset and rather I'm
aiding those people that we are trying
to contain.
I mean,
I always,
as a European myself,
I always felt it was great and I could
just cross the border.
When I lived in Germany,
I thought it was great,
just crossed the border into the
Netherlands or Belgium or France without
having to show my passport.
It's great.
But the problem is if you have a system
like open borders,
you also need adequate security to back
this up.
And what the Belgium example shows you
is that right now we are not having the
security apparatus that can safeguard us
was having open boarders because Belgium
is failing to contain the threat and
that's what they are doing and have been
doing for a long time.
And these people can travel freely
across the entire European Union.
It's a little different with the UK
because you have to cross some water and
it's more complex,
but into France or Germany or the
Netherlands,
then we all have,
we're having a problem and we have to
talk about it.
And I'm not even,
I'm not very partisan when it comes to
dessert and tie a yes EU until bud bay.
But I do think that we have to honestly
talk about the now your abilities of
open borders at the moment.
And that is true for terrorists as much
as it is for refugees.
Do you know,
is the vetting process for the migrants
and the immigrants,
is it the same in each country?
Because if they're all,
let's say they're coming through Greece,
if Greece has more,
uh,
processes by which they can get in.
Well then if you,
once you're in Greece,
if you can then get anywhere in Europe,
I could see why you would be pretty
pissed if you were in France and Greece
had lead lacks,
uh,
you know,
ways to get people in.
Well,
the truth is that all of these countries
are actually overwhelmed.
They cannot process all these people in
time that,
that day arriving.
And the truth is also that many of them
are just throwing away their papers so
you have no way to even,
uh,
you know,
check who they are,
where they're coming from,
and the truth they thought so that many
of them actually not coming from Syria.
They also coming from countries like
Afghanistan and Eritrea.
And I feel like the biggest problem at
the moment is that we are only treating
the symptoms.
We are not treating the root cause
because what is the plan for Eritrea?
Nobody's talking about Eritrea.
What are we going to do about the
situation in,
in Eritrea to make sure that not more
people that coming.
I mean we have to look at these
countries and the situation in these
countries and we have to ask ourselves
what can we do to change the situation
on the ground and to have people within
their own region.
Because the truth is that even a notch
country like Germany,
a welcoming country like Germany cannot
take in all the people that need help.
And how would you explain to someone
from Libya that yes,
we are taking in people from Syria and
Eritrea and Afghanistan,
but no,
you Olivia,
please stay away.
We can't discriminate there.
And the truth is that we cannot take in
all these people.
And my fear is that uncle amber sent a
very dangerous message in the sense that
people now believe everybody can come.
And we,
if you look at the situation in Germany
at the moment,
you see they're already struggling.
I know that the government is not
willing to admit that,
but if you look at the situation on the
ground,
they are really,
really struggling.
And the opposition within even her own
party is growing by the day.
Yeah.
So this is an example where when I hear
this,
I always say,
well,
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions.
So Angela Merkel,
her intentions by bringing these people
in where to help immigrants,
right?
Help migrants,
helped people that needed help integrate
them into society.
Obviously Germany has a long history of
xenophobia and and the Holocaust,
so they were trying to do the right
thing.
I don't think,
you know,
I talked to people who think that she
maliciously is trying to destroy the
country.
I,
I don't quite think it's that.
I think she was trying to do something
good here,
but then because of I guess the
questionable the vetting process or just
allowing too many people and these
people come in and then the system just
can't take it.
And then when people in other countries
see what's happening in Germany,
they don't want it happening there.
So this whole thing is just has just
snowballed and it is it too late?
Have we already left this?
That the only will be that far right?
Parties are going to win throughout
Europe.
What,
first of all,
I agree with you that I don't think
there's an eba master plan of,
of Angola to destroy Germany or to
Europe Union.
I don't believe that.
I believe for whatever reason she
believed that if the right thing to do
the problem is.
I recently spoke to friends of mine who
sits in the German parliament for her
party for the video and he said even now
we have still not having a discussion
about quota,
you know,
there,
there is no end to this,
that even the people within her own
party don't know where it stops.
And that of course gives people like the
far right in Germany and we see,
you know,
the piggy to movement and we see the,
what is called the alternative for
Germany.
These people are really gaining support
and really gaining ground and these are
of course not the people that we wanted
to handle the beat over to.
And I know that there are people who
tried remain to sti movements like piggy
die and say,
Oh,
you know,
they are just concerned citizen to take
to the streets and exercise their right
to free speech.
But you know,
I,
I'm quite familiar with DNRC seed in
Gemini and I looked at footage from
Pegida demonstrations and do you see
very well known people from the Neo
Nazis taking part in these
demonstrations?
And I'm not a fan of guilty by
association.
I mean,
you cannot always control who comes to
your demonstration.
Sure.
But it was fun.
I mean this guy gave an interview to one
of,
of Germany's a well known political
magazines and very openly admitted that
the NPD,
which is the Neo Nazi party in the
country,
helped begin to organize this particular
demonstration in the east of Germany.
So you see already,
you know the lines blurring between the
populist.
Right.
And really the,
the extreme extreme,
right?
Yeah.
I'm curious little,
let's dig into Paquita a little bit more
because I had Tommy Robinson on the show
and you know,
a lot of people were very angry at me.
I got a lot of hate mail for,
for even just talking to the guy now.
I think in the context of the hour of
our conversation,
he did basically make the distinction
between ideas and people and all of
those things.
And after the interview,
which I thought was pretty fruitful,
people did send me tweets that he sent
out years before where he was talking
about all Muslims and there clearly was
an element of bigotry to it.
I can't vet my guests tweets from,
from five years ago unfortunately.
Um,
but what,
what do you make of someone like him
that I think,
from what I can tell,
he's trying to make the distinction.
He and I know he's left organizations
when it's gone too far.
Right.
Or when they were bigoted against black
people.
Um,
I guess that just shows the complexity
of this,
that these organizations,
they have all kinds of people in them.
Yeah,
I mean Tommy Robinson is a,
is a very,
um,
tricky.
I don't want to dive too much into this
because to be fair,
I'm not familiar with every everything
that he's doing at the moment.
I mean,
I,
I what I know is because I,
uh,
we worked with Quilliam as well and I
know Martina was,
that he was really trying to get him
away from the edl and at least making an
attempt to engage with him and explained
to him the difference between,
you know,
the religion of Islam,
which is a set of leave and Islam as an
ideology and Muslims as people and Islam
as,
as a system of beliefs.
And I think to some extent,
if you're listening to what he's saying
now,
he has definitely made some progress,
but I don't,
I don't want to,
uh,
um,
sort of approve of everything that he
says because I still believe that some
of the views that he holds a problematic
to say the least.
And for instances,
involvement,
movement and the pig Edo movement,
that is something that I do not approve
off and I do not believe that piggy,
that isn't legitimate political.
Well,
it,
it legitimate in the sense that these
people have the right to speak their
minds,
um,
but not legitimate in the sense that I
would ever support their views.
Sure.
And that's why I wanted to have him on
the show because I can't figure out what
someone thinks unless I talked to them
and maybe he secretly was harboring
ideas that he didn't allow me to hear.
Um,
but I think we got a little closer to
the truth maybe by talking to him.
I'm curious,
you brought up my jacket and my jade is
a,
has been on the show and we've become
friendly.
Do you think his job here is the
hardest,
do you think it's much harder than what
I'm doing or what you are doing or what
Tommy's doing because he's trying to
reform the religion from the inside and
I see the most hate and the worst things
that people on the left white people on
the left in America say about Majid,
a brown Muslim man from Egypt.
Uh,
so he's getting the worst from everybody
I think is his job the toughest?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I don't envy invite by any means.
I mean I get a lot of hate mail and all
of that,
but that is nothing compared to a,
to what he goes through.
And if you look at some of the things
that people say to him,
you know,
you and I would never get away with
things.
Some,
something similar to,
to the Brown men.
I mean we would rightly called a racist
and a bigot and a and in a summer job.
So I write hugely admire what he's
trying to do.
And obviously there are two types of
people that I admire enormously.
You have,
on the one hand,
you have people that are in Hirsi Ali
who's left her faith and it's now
campaigning really for people to have
the right to leave Islam and to
criticize the religion and then you have
people like Margaret who's obviously had
a change of heart,
but it's still a Muslim and he wants to
reform his faith from inside and you
know,
these are probably one of the most
important people at the moment that we
should support and align ourselves with
because let's be under no illusion
whatsoever.
We cannot win this fight without the
support and the friendship with people
from inside the community.
We need Muslim leaders.
We need Muslims themselves within within
their communities to speak up for a,
for a form of Islam that is compatible
with the modern world.
And we see basically we see,
we see similar things happening in
Jordan and Egypt were President Sisi and
King Abdullah.
I now finally,
you know,
finding the words to address some of
these problems and that is hugely
important.
Whatever else you may be.
Think about what President Sisi is doing
to journalists and to he human rights
activists and I certainly don't approve
of that,
but I think he plays an important role
in fighting Islamic extremism.
Yeah.
So that again,
that goes to the precarious position
that people that really care for human
rights or put in so cc is doing terrible
things for human rights and minorities.
And he's basically,
he's basically a military leader that
took power by a coup after they had the,
you know,
the actual democratic elections that
sort of ended up going the wrong way.
Um,
but we have to play ball with him
because at least Egypt is a stable
country.
So if you care about human rights,
it's like you have to play ball with
these strong men.
And then at the same time the strong men
do terrible things.
It almost sounds like a repeat of Saddam
Hussein.
Not to say he's doing the types of
violence to his own people that Saddam
was doing.
But is that just the best wherever going
to get out of this part of the world?
Well,
you know,
it's always a mixture of optimism and
realism.
Mothers in the Middle East,
there are no pretty solution to
anything.
I mean,
even if you look at the curt who I
greatly support,
there were still problems within cardiac
societies that need to be addressed.
So you do not find a perfect regime or
country in the middle.
He is not even Israel.
I mean,
I'm a huge supporter of Israel.
I'm a self declared proud dryness.
I loved it.
I loved the state of Israel.
I think it's a beautiful country and a
democratic country,
but Israel is not perfect and I
disagreed with this on certain things.
Now obviously Egypt is a much more
extreme example,
but I think people have the intellectual
capacity.
So make a difference and say,
I completely disagree with this human
rights record,
but I do acknowledge that he is trying
to,
you know,
trigger a debate about Islam and the
Muslim world that we really,
really need and what the,
the only option that we didn't really
have is to say like,
we cooperate with him on that,
but we don't stop criticizing him when
he arrested journalists or human rights
activist or anyone else.
Yeah.
Um,
what,
what do you make of the West's
fascination or the left's fascination?
I should say,
not the,
it's everyone's fascination.
Everyone's fascination with Israel.
I mean,
this is a piece of land that's the size
of New Jersey.
It has one international airport.
You can drive east and west of it.
The border to border in a couple of
hours,
I think like four hours north and south
in like six or eight hours.
I mean,
it's an absurdly tiny piece of land that
gets all the media play a that people
are obsessed with.
You know,
I,
I feel similarly to how you just
described it.
Um,
and of course it's not perfect and
they're in a very precarious place.
It's hard when you have a tiny little
border,
um,
and the Middle East is a mess and
sometimes people die,
but what are you make it just the
fascination and the endless of the
United Nations endless assault on the
one tiny little democracy there.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Bizarre.
And I know I'm going to get 100 hate
emails just holding Israel in a
democracy and not an apart hype stated
engages in the genocide of the
Palestinian people,
which by the way would be the only
genocide ever to take place in history
where the victim populations increases.
Right,
right.
So just to begin,
can you just really lay that out?
I mean the,
the population of Gaza since 1967.
It's sometimes something like four times
bigger or even eight times bigger,
I think than it was back then.
So this is not,
it's the reverse of the genocide.
Not to say everything's perfect,
but it is certainly not a genotype
upside down.
Yeah,
it's the only Jennifer in history,
you were the victim population.
Having the alleged victim population has
increased,
that goes for both Gaza and the West
Bank,
and if you look at the standard of
living and something like health care
and life expectancy,
this has all improved over the years.
No,
I'm not saying that the Palestinians are
not suffering and that,
you know,
Israel is always right in the way that
it deals with the problem.
Not at all.
But to say that Israel is engaging in a
genocide,
I mean,
the word genocide is a very,
very serious allegation.
It is the crime of all crimes that is
just absolutely bizarre and frankly,
it,
it relativizes the concept of genocide
and it relativizes to cry of people that
have actually committed a genocide.
And the most bizarre thing about it all
is that the people who accuse Israel of
engaging in genocide are often or very
often aligned with Hamas.
We just actually preaching a genocide,
the genocide against the Jewish people.
That is the irony,
the episode today about it.
All
right.
So that's what I've tried to explain to
people many times because people will
say that somehow on this issue,
uh,
um,
this right,
we maniac.
I'm for two states where you have to
have two actors that are willing to have
two states.
If Hamas is only willing to have one
state,
uh,
you know,
look,
Israel left Gaza.
There's not one Jew in guys there,
right?
Hitler would love the place.
There's actually a store called Hitler.
It's a clothing store,
a in Gaza.
So it's like,
what do you want them to do?
That's why it seems that's one of the
ones where religion is so tied to it
because in my opinion,
they just simply,
they just don't want Jews there.
No,
you're absolutely right.
I mean if you not just listening what
Hamas is saying,
but also to what president Abbas's
thing.
I mean,
if the baby.
No,
Tanya was saying the same things about
Arabs and Palestinians that the
Palestinian Authority,
you're saying about Jews,
not just Israeli Jews in general.
I mean,
the entire word would probably go up in
flames.
It's completely ridiculous.
And what is also completely ridiculous.
This visa interdependence theory that
people some how believed that if only we
were to solve this problem and this tiny
strip of land at all the ills of,
of,
of the Arab Muslim world would disappear
and to thin out.
I mean how is what we're seeing in
theory are related to the problem in
Palestine.
There is no relation,
there is no relation and this unhealthy
obsession with Israel is,
is just.
I can't wrap my head around it because
again,
I'm not saying that it's rent as perfect
and I consider myself a critical friend
of Israel that reserves the right to
criticize us were always read this
wrong.
Sure.
But if I look around in the region and I
see what what's happening in Syria and
what the Saudis are doing to women in
their own country,
why are we,
why are we having a part hide weeks at
our universities for Israel and never
for Saudi Arabia.
Why are we having mass demonstrations on
European street for the Palestinians in
Gaza and the West Bank?
Well,
if suffering,
of course,
but that's nothing compared to what
Bashar Al Assad is doing to them in
Syria,
starving them to death.
Actually really engaging in math.
A lot of Palestinian.
No,
you don't hear these people talking
about it because it's not really about
Israel.
I mean these,
you know,
it's not,
it's not really.
It's not really about the Palestinians
really.
These people are really pro
Palestinians.
What they really are.
It's anti Israel.
Right?
So that's the fascinating part.
I mean,
there was the Yarmouk refugee camp in
Syria,
which means there should be no refugee
camps in any of these Arab countries for
Palestinians,
but they've kept Palestinians in refugee
camps.
They don't even let them become citizens
aside,
killed about 2000 of them within the
last two years.
Nobody.
Nobody seems to care.
So it was part of that,
that people just don't care about
history.
So for example,
they'll say,
well,
go back to 1967,
but it's not as if there was peace
before 1967.
And also,
uh,
I'm pretty sure that the Westbank was
part of Jordan and that guy's always
part of Egypt.
So it's not as if the Palestinians had
to state then,
so it's like people just don't,
the people love narrative over fact and
I'm seeing this bleed into almost
everything these days.
Yes.
And it's old,
so I mean they call it finer and finer
them today,
what there are taking,
but what they really very often mean is,
is Judas,
you know,
sign and it's just become a clean word,
the word to describe Jews.
So it actually has a lot to do with
antisemitism,
which never went away.
It took different forms and different
ways of describing it,
but it really comes down in many cases
to the fact that people just don't want
you staff.
Yeah.
Now you realize people are going to say
you're a paid Mossad agent and I'm
opposed to paid Mossad agent and we're
working together on this.
You know,
I'm really angry now that you blew my
cover.
I was trying so hard.
You thought you were being slick,
but they don't pay me enough to really
keep it a secret.
That's the thing,
you know,
uh,
I get a call after the show,
you know,
and I have to explain myself.
All right,
well,
uh,
okay,
wait,
so we only have a few minutes left.
I want to circle back a little bit too
to the European problem.
I saw that this week in Denmark,
uh,
that they're looking into stripping
citizenship of moms who are preaching
hate and preaching things against the
state in Denmark.
Now I,
my whole ethos is about free speech.
Uh,
everything that I do here is about free
speech.
So I'm very torn on this one because I
would basically say that people can say
anything that they want as long as
they're not inciting to violence.
Now,
it seems to me that these moms are
probably going as close to the line on
that as possible.
If they were preaching to take down the
state,
uh,
there's the,
at least a inclination or hint that it
may be through violent means,
uh,
where,
where do you fall on that?
Because I know you're huge on free
speech and secular values also.
I am.
But,
uh,
I'm,
I'm of course also have to believe that
about all we have to have.
God,
I'm the lives of innocent people living
in our country and we just had a case in
the UK this week that the mom of the
largest mosque in in Scotland praised
the assassination of the anti blast for
me activists in Pakistan a couple of
years ago.
And then just hours later,
a shopkeeper who posted a,
a message on facebook congratulating
Christians for Isa was brutally,
brutally murdered,
like a Muslim
by a Muslim because he is,
he belongs to,
to,
to the Ahmadiyya Muslims,
which is a,
a,
a largely peaceful and progressive
movement within the Islamic community.
And within the Muslim world,
these people are often called heretics
and a state.
And you don't have to be surprised that
if the mom or the largest mosque in
Scotland believes that it's perfectly
legitimate to murder people for last,
for me,
what he actually meets with free speech.
But what these people call blast for me.
That we then see people actually being
murdered on our street in the name of
their religion.
And I know people would say no again,
no,
he was not a Muslim,
but he was not in.
It has nothing to do with Islam,
what it has something to do with Islam
because what these emom is preaching is
based on Islamic teaching and there is
no way around it.
I mean we can deny the problem and many
people still prefer to do that,
but it is a part of Islam and we need to
talk about it.
Right?
So now I know you've made this
distinction several times even in the
course of this interview,
but that there's a political component
to this.
So it's not just that the Islamists have
to blow up things and then maybe force
our governments to take away our own
freedoms to protect us,
but that there's a political ideology
that they'll use the rights that the
West grants them to preach these things,
to turn their own populace against us.
When you start going down that route,
it all starts sounding like a big
conspiracy or something that there
really is this massive invasion and I
don't want to start using the
fearmongering techniques that the right
uses.
But that that's real,
right,
that there's a political element that
goes beyond violence here,
I'm third years ago,
that Muslims don't need to,
you know,
infiltrated western countries.
They just do this by,
by immigrating to these countries and
then getting a lot of children because
that.
That brings me back to what I said
before.
We're not just fighting the jihadis,
those who commit violence.
We also have to deal with the Islamist
who wants to impose that way of life on
our societies,
but also with a conservative Muslims who
are maybe not Islam is and maybe not
jihadists,
but who at least to a certain degree
with some of the things that these
people are saying.
Because if you look at opinion polls,
and I know this brings me dangerously
close to what happened to to Sam Harris
on that show with Ben Affleck looking at
opinion polls.
I mean legitimate opinion polls,
not some fringe,
crazy conspiracy fearmongering opinion
polls.
If you look at what people in the Muslim
world think about apostates converting
from the religion,
leaving the religion,
it's shocking.
It is shocking the percentage of people
who believe it is legitimate to use
violence against people just leaving the
religion or converting to another
religion is to me absolutely shocking.
Do you think the West is fundamentally
doing something wrong here that somehow,
and I can even feel it when I'm talking
to you knowing that we'd go out of our
way to make this distinction over and
over,
that we still feel we have to guard our
words somehow in all this and again,
as we've talked about,
that sort of gives the strength to the
to the right,
but that the west is doing something
wrong in that we're not selling.
Why freedom is good anymore.
There was a time where it was like it
was cool to really stand up for Western
values,
stand up for free speech and religious
plurality and rights of minorities and
all of those things and for all the
faults of the West and for,
for wars that we probably shouldn't have
got into.
Although they were,
as I said at the top of the show,
there were a thousand year old blood
flute feuds going on in the Middle East,
far boat before America was a country.
Um,
but that nobody really stands up.
There aren't public figures anymore that
stand up and say,
you know what,
what we're doing here in the UK is still
good.
We still have more integration here than
they do in most other places.
Certainly in the United States where
people still want to come.
Do you think we're just,
we're just not doing a good sell job
anymore.
I think you raised two interesting
points here.
One is that yes,
indeed.
Every time,
like if such an interview I think about
what am I going to say because I know it
will be people out there watching are
just waiting for me to slip.
Not even intentionally,
just a snip and say something they can
twist and turn and make me sound like a
racist and a bigot and you know that
there are people like John and Glenn
Greenwald who do this on purpose and
have their own malicious agenda and they
know quite well they are misrepresenting
what we're saying,
but they're saying it anyway because
they are too afraid to debate us with
ideas so all they can resort to is,
you know,
smearing us and trying to silence that.
That is one point.
And the second point that you raised
about not selling ourselves anymore.
Absolutely.
And you guys in America are doing more
of a better job at this than we do in
Europe because you're still what?
Yeah,
I mean if you look at it from a European
perspective now I left in Washington dc
for Harvey.
Yeah.
And I was really surprised how proud the
Americans really are about America.
I mean if you come from from Europe,
it's still,
you still feel proud about America at
least compared to two years.
And we have to be part from this
perpetual sense of guilt,
you know?
And and culture of self destruction and
self blaming that we have somewhat to
blame for all the ills of the Middle
East.
So I'm not saying the colonial period is
period was pretty,
you know,
we didn't do terrible things to people
but this is not the reason why people
blow themselves up in Nigeria or
Indonesia.
This comes down to the Islam,
Ms.audio
that g and these people can ignite at as
much as they like and they pretend it
all comes down to us.
And again,
it's what George W dot Bush called the
soft bigotry of low expectations because
somewhat,
you know,
these brown people can not be
responsible for their own faded must
always come down to us.
It must always have something to do with
us.
They can say that as long as they like,
it doesn't change the fact it's not
true.
And as you can explain,
the global and I,
I believe magic now was called the
global Islamist insurgency.
You can only explain that and its roots
with the ideology of Islam,
Islam and not with Western foreign
policy.
Yeah.
You know,
it's so funny.
So many of my guests have mentioned the
phrase,
the soft bigotry of low expectations and
many times on the show I kept quoting,
I thought it was bill Maher that had
coined the phrase.
So I felt good about it.
Then I learned it was a George W dot
Bush.
It was one of his speech writers.
I've been saying it less,
but maybe that's the phrase that George
W dot Bush gave us that,
uh,
that we don't have to be upset about.
No.
And uh,
I mean,
it's quite funny,
you know,
I talked about Iraq,
the,
and you know,
they will actually,
people who would have been happy at the
top of George w Bush and toppled Saddam
Hussein.
And that really brings us back to the
absurdity of the left and in everything
that we talked about today,
for all his faults and by no means
George W Bush was not perfect,
but he was also not a sudden the same.
Yeah.
All right,
so final thoughts to wrap all this up.
If you had a crystal ball and you were
looking five or 10 years into the future
of where Europe is going to be a,
the state of Jihad in Islam,
Islam and all that,
or are you hopeful?
It doesn't feel very hopeful right now.
The only grain that I can get this
hopeful is that these conversations are
happening and at least that the free
thinkers aren't feeling as held hostage,
uh,
between jihadists and leftists.
So I think that's the hope for me,
but I don't know how big,
how really hopeful I can
hang my hat on that.
What I'm.
I am by nature an optimist.
I couldn't do the job if I were not an
optimist.
And I do think there is reason for hope
because if I look at the emails that I
received,
a tweet that I received,
the private messages that I received,
the feedback that I received,
when I talk to people,
people are waking up in our own
countries.
I mean,
I have many people come to me and say
like,
Oh,
you actually saying what I would like to
say,
but either they're,
you know,
they're too afraid to say it because
they'll be called a racist or they don't
have the rhetoric to really bring across
their views were just why shows like
yours are so important.
But also people in the Muslim world.
I mean the Muslim women that we work
with really no longer want to live on
the oppression,
who don't want to be treated as second
class citizens who have the right to
education and to opportunity in life.
The free thinkers,
the poets,
the gentleness,
the activist,
minorities like homosexual converts,
atheist.
These are the most important people in
the Muslim world at the moment.
And who deserves all the respect and
support that we can give them.
And I think if we can forge a genuine
alliance between those in the Muslim
world,
want to see change and want to make
Islam compatible with the modern world
and us who are not afraid to speak.
How to probe about the problems of the
religion and about the ideology.
Because you know,
the irony is that by denying all of
this,
you were actually aiding the extremists
because you're taking away,
you're taking away the justification for
those who want to bring about change,
why they want to bring about change.
If you don't name the problem,
if you take away the problem,
what are these people going to do?
So that's something we need to realize.
Yeah.
At the top of the show I said,
you know,
as you've said that a religion is just a
set of ideas and if there was a
political ideology or political party,
let's say that it was an offshoot of the
Republicans here in the United States,
and it said,
we're going to throw gays off roofs and
we're going to put women in Burkas and
we're going to oppress minorities.
Well then the progressive's would be
going bonkers and they'd be,
they'd be calling them the racist
instead.
Uh,
well I think you know,
where I'm going with this.
Well Julie,
it was really a pleasure talking to you
and was that.
It was my pleasure.
Thank you so much for having me on your
show.
Yeah,
thank you.
And you guys can find out more about
Julie and the work she does.
Follow her on twitter.
It's Ms Dot Julie is and check out her
work@hiscenter.org
center,
spelled the,
uh,
the British way.
Catch new episodes of the Rubin report
each week on Ora.tv,
youtube,
and now featured on the aura tv app on
your Roku player.